côté nicolas sarkozy était en visite
aujourd'hui à calais trois ans après la
fermeture de sangatte les réfugiés sont
toujours nombreux dans la région entre 5
et 800 migrants sont encore candidats au
passage en angleterre
nicolas sarkozy s'est prononcé en faveur
d'un renforcement des mesures contre
l'immigration clandestine sur place
mathias hillion le rang des bois
trois ans après la fermeture de sangatte
ils sont toujours là toujours avec le
même rêve passer coûte que coûte de
l'autre côté de la manche jeu en
angleterre
et vous pensez que c'est encore possible
de passer en angleterre 50 50
mais selon nicolas sarkozy ces migrants
sont beaucoup moins nombreux qu'en 2002
en visite à calais le ministre de
l'intérieur a défendu son bilan en
matière de lutte contre l'immigration
clandestine
la situation s'est arrangée par ce que
il y avait au moment du centre de
sangatte il faut plus de migrants qui
n'y en a aujourd'hui donc mon devoir de
ministre de l'intérieur s'était diminuer
la pression migratoire
c'est ce qui a été fait cas fermeture du
centre
pour le reste j'observe depuis quelques
mois une aggravation de la situation et
bien j'essaie d'y apporter une réponse
depuis le début de l'année le nombre de
migrants interpellés par la police est
en hausse de 14% par rapport à 2004
beaucoup d'entre eux ne sont pas
reconductible aux frontières on a ici
dans cette foule des gens qui ont fait
des demandes d'asile qui ont des papiers
et qui sont quand même dehors et qui
sont loin d'être conductible puisqu'ils
ont toutes les chances de pouvoir rester
en france par la suite
je voudrais que monsieur sarkozy un jour
de ses yeux voient ces gens-là sangatte
ou pas qu'elle ait demeure le port
français le plus proche de l'angleterre
un pôle d'attraction pour les migrants
du monde entier